Luke here at the oor boys YouTube
channel and for the next four days I'm
all alone in the wilderness of Alaska
I'm coming face to face with giant
grizzly bears hunting for my food
collecting washed up whalebones and
exploring a remote island in the Gulf of
[Music]
Alaska
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
right well there goes my
ride yeah I'm not going to see him for 4
days I am on a remote island on the edge
of the Gulf of Alaska at the very top of
the Pacific Ocean if you were to go that
direction as far as you can go the next
land you would hit is
Antarctica
well tonight I'm going to be staying in
this off-grid dry cabin and it's
maintained by the National Forest
Service and they have these cabins all
over the Wilderness of Alaska many of
them you can only reach by plane or boat
and these cabins are in some of the
coolest places in Alaska so we got the
bear prooof lock look at this we got a
bed got a table chairs yeah there's a
wood stove that looks like like that's a
heating oil
stove got some
utensils some books and things some
puzzles and uh oh looks there's a loft
here it's a nice big sleeping space up
here in the Attic if you come here in
the winter time this will be the warmest
place to sleep tell you what this is
going to do very nicely but the sun's
setting I got to get unpacked
quick
this is pretty perfect but there is one
thing I'm a little anxious about water
I'm not sure where we're going to get
our water
from oh there we go see this trash can
it's underneath the drain spout there's
a little screen here so this is a rain
catch so I'm going to drink out of a
trash can that's why I brought my filter
okay just hang up the dirty water and
the gravity feeds it through the filter
down the hose and into my water bottle
it filters about a liter every 2 minutes
it's pretty
[Applause]
fast
brought my old shotgun and I brought my
rifle we're geared up for just about
anything we can legally
shoot I brought along my liquid fuel
stove I love this thing it runs off of
almost any type of fuel including un
Leed and
Diesel getting a little cold in here
let's uh let's get a fire
started
[Music]
well you know now that I'm settled in
I'm starting to get a little hungry and
uh I think a little dessert before bed
might be in order it's a marry and berry
pie I actually put this in my checked
bag and to cover it in a little tin foil
let it sit right there should warm up in
a few minutes I'm pretty excited to eat
that pie but it's got to last me the
whole trip so I got to pce
myself oh check it out I found a
replacement for my lost nighte found one
used on
eBay there we go some marry and berry
pie still is putting out the heat
keeping my bum
warm this is a good way to start out the
trip well guys it's late I'm going to
bed I've got an early start tomorrow I
will see you guys in the
morning
well good morning it's a little bit cold
in here but the fire is warming the
cabin up pretty quick and I'm going to
start making some
breakfast smoked pork gel bacon
here
smoked pork jow bacon eggs and
toast all
righty no that is so
good that's
good
all right I think it's time to go
explore the
island now I've never hunted for deer
before and I've never hunted on this
island before but my understanding is
that the deer tend to stay away from the
beaches in the summertime when the
weather's good and then as it gets cold
they get forced down off the mountains
and come down well it's still pretty
nice so my guess is I've got to go
hiking
up
there you go that's Blacktail deer
poop I can smell rotting salmon which
means this is be country there's a
salmon there's a
salmon there's a salmon there's the
salmon come from the ocean into these
rivers to spawn and as soon as they
spawn they die of old age so there's
just dead salmon everywhere smells like
a rotten Fish Market you see all these
salmon pulled up onto the bank that
means something's been eating them look
at this this is all piles of dead salmon
and look at this this right here is a
bear print this is the rear paw of a
bear anytime you have salmon like this
there will be Bears this Trail I'm
walking on could easily be a Bear
Trail there it is these are bear prints
right
here look at a size comparison to my
hand see each of his toes right there
his claws that's his hind leg that's his
front leg generally speaking for each
inch across on the front pad is how tall
the bear is it's a very average Siz
grizzly bear right there it's probably
four 5T tall a big grizzly bear will be
over 10 ft tall and that's measured from
nose to tip of
tail look there's some salmon right in
there you can see there're just all
those little white spots are dead
rotting salmon and there's a couple live
ones right there the Salmon's body is
actually rot before they die and so you
can see that live salmon right there has
mold all over his tail check it out guys
there's a grizzly bear right there it's
right there in the bushes I don't think
he knows I'm here yet I'm downwind from
him grizzly bears are actually in season
right now and this gun would take him
down but what am I going to do with the
dead grizzly
bear well I'm just going to go back this
way seems to be a little side trail that
goes up this
hill can see this faint Trail kind of
running like this is a game Trail
probably for deer so we're going to go
and walk along this game Trail and see
if we can't find
anything that's a deer
poop look at
that that looks like the skull of a baby
bear that's crazy
every once in a while I pop out on one
of these little clearings and I just
stop and wait and
listen that looks pretty fresh to
me that's the beach head of the river we
were at where we saw the
bear
I've got a pretty good view up here but
I haven't seen any signs of life it is
the middle of the day and that's the
worst time to see animals so I think I
might start working my way back to the
cabin and maybe I'll see something on
the way
back coming up over this Ridge and I
spooked something I think it was a
bedding deer in the middle middle of the
day like this they kind of hunker down
and digest their food from the morning I
looked up just in time to see a bunch of
branches moving and that was about
it well made it
back I hiked for about 5 and 1/2 hours
climbed about 12200 ft in elevation and
did about 5 miles I'm going to grab my
fishing rod and we're going to see about
doing some fishing rumor has it that
there's a river 1 mile east of here that
has cutthroat trout and salmon in it so
I think I'm going to hike over there and
take a peek at
it oh there's some more bear poop it's a
lot of bear poop on this Trail random
piece of plastic with tooth holes in it
some bear gave it a taste bears are a
little bit like babies they like to put
things in their mouths when they don't
know what it is oh look at this
oh looks like something ate a raven
right
there there you go that's the mountain I
climbed this
morning oh look at these bear
prints that is a large coyote print and
that's an average bear
print hey check this
out this is the vertebrae of a whale
right here is that crazy
it's another chunk of a whalebone look
there's like a teeth marks in it right
there look at that another big piece of
whale bone woo That's
Heavy looks like deer bones to
me see some ducks up ahead I think I uh
might have to get dinner they're
starting to get in range when you can
see the color on their head getting
ready to
fly I got
one oh there we go got a nice fat duck
now I want to see if we can spot any Tru
or salmon in
here just saw a fish jump in the water
up there oh there's a few salmon that's
a pink salmon right there that's what
that is see the bottom of the creek is
just covered in Bear prints there's a
couple spawned out pink salmon but
that's about
it look at that it's a sand
dollar whoa
oh thing weighs like 15 lbs the rib bone
of a whale look at
this man that looks like a piece of the
skull or maybe a
pelvis that is so
cool I'm going to use my Garmin in reach
to text Becca and have her Google the
federal regulations for whalebones if I
can keep this I'm totally bringing it
back I'll figure a way to get into my
bags oh made
it got to clean that duck but don't want
to do that by the cabin that'll attract
grizzly bears for sure all
right oh this weather is so nice it it's
been such a cold wet summer I got snowed
on last week a
lot well I've been using my inre to text
my wife and I found a little something
about finding whalebones apparently in
Alaska whenever you find whale carcasses
or whale bones you're supposed to report
it to a biologist here in the state well
tomorrow Becca's going to go ahead and
call the biologist and tell her what I
found and uh we're going to see what I
get to do with the whale
bones
all
right
[Music]
we got ourselves a feast
here we got roasted duck breast lingen
Berry Jam Pinta pork gels fried onions
fonded potatoes and gravy I don't know
I'm pretty happy with this I think this
looks pretty good this duck with a
little lingen Berry sauce and gravy is
good I that's the best wild duck I've
ever had how would worked out really
well tell you what it is late I am very
sore and I am very full of food I am
going to go to bed and I will see you in
the
morning good
morning looks like the first thing I got
to do today is do some
dishes
before I left on this trip my brother
gave me a jar of home homade rhubarb
syrup so I've got a little bit of that
in this jar and I'm going to put that on
my pancakes it is pretty
amazing oh that was
good well I'm going to make another
attempt at trying to find a deer I
definitely think that near the top of
the mountain was better I saw more deer
sign up there for
sure
I mean look at this
Trail it's all deer
tracks oh my legs in butter asleep well
it's a little past lunchtime and I'm
getting hungry so I'm going to hike down
the mountain about 2 miles back to the
cabin
there's a
deer I'm tired well I'm hungry I think
it's time for some
lunch
[Music]
just eating a little snack while I make
sandwiches
grilled cheese sandwich and tomato soup
that's just hard to
beat this is such a great cabin I mean
look at that view that's pretty well
guys I had an interesting development
over lunch turns out if you find any
whalebones you're supposed to report it
to a biologist here in Alaska and Becca
did and the biologist wants me to go
ahead and photograph all the bones I
found and send her to the GPS locations
and some of the more intact pieces I'm
going to bring back to Anchorage
apparently whether or not you can keep
the bones or not depends on what species
of whale it is so since I'm much better
at finding whale bones than I am at
finding deer I figure I'm going to go do
some beach combing and I'm going to go
document all the whale bones I can
find
and I'm going to go out of limb and say
that's a deer
skeleton there's a eagle feather right
there look here's another
one oh look at
that so much of this Driftwood looks
like bone it tricks me half the
time that hadn't me fooled
like a bunch of buoys look here's some
deer prints some little snip prints and
bear
prints oh check this out look at
this it's like the lower jaw of a dog
dolphin or a
whale look at the size of that tooth
right there that is so
cool oh look at
this it's a vertebrae disc right there
there's no way these are coming off from
the same animal that jaw and tooth was
way too small for those vertebrae oh
look at this there's another one right
there look at
that look at at the size of that
Barnacle the skull of some animal oh
look at
this look at that two of them right
there I mean look at how big those are
that's a big animal it's a really big
animal oh check it out there's a Croc
bone right
there
well I've walked as far as I can go this
direction without getting my feet wet
time to turn around and head back the
other
direction check this
out look at
that this is just one small bone in a
whale's back look at the size of these
things
oh look at
that I don't know what that is but it's
fresh
those look like those belong to a
deer look at that that's a shark egg
right there you can see where the little
shark pup hatched
out oh there's a school of salmon right
there in the river
oh man this is
gorgeous check it out this is bull
Kil it's an enormous piece of seaweed
and it's
edible you can pickle these little rings
of kelp and they're really
good salty and crunchy but the best
thing to do with bul kelp is pretend
you're Indiana
Jones
I remember doing that as a kid smacking
myself in the face so
hard I'm going to hurt myself oh that's
fun I remember when I was young me and
my brother found some buold kelp and
started whipping each other with
it
still can't believe all these whale
bones washed up on one Beach and they're
obviously from different whales too I'm
going to try the best I can to pack
these up and get these back to Anchorage
and uh we'll see what the biologist has
to say you it's getting late I'm going
to make a little dinner honestly that
tomato soup and grilled cheese sandwich
was so good I'm going to do that
again
been looking forward to
this oh that was
good it is a beautiful day and there is
a beautiful beach out here I think I
need to make a
bonfire
[Music]
oh good morning oh it's cozy in my bag
but I've got so much I need to do this
morning turn on my lights got a couple
rechargeable bicycle lights I use them
as flood lighting whenever I'm out
camping so I can film I've been using
the same battery for 4 days all right
let's go get some
water let's
see all
[Music]
right
got a nice little breakfast here got
some pork gell bacon got some hot MUSC
cereal some hot chocolate and an
apple oh my goodness I am full well uh
I've got to go use the little boys
room all
right must say this is one of the
prettier ouses I've ever been in I'm uh
I'm going to turn this off
now oh can't believe how dark it still
is it's almost 8:00 and there's just
barely light in the sky this time of
year the days get shorter very quickly
we lose almost 15 minutes of daylight
every single day and the further north
you go in Alaska the more extreme it
gets if you're above the Arctic Circle
there's days in the wintertime where the
Sun never
Rises
tell you what this has been an awesome
place to Camp I would love to come back
here with the whole family but I've got
to figure out some way to get these
bones into my check bags that's going to
be
interesting I got my bags checked in I'm
waiting at my terminal my flight should
be here any moment
now
[Music]
so hard to
see from the
moment well since getting home I began
the process of registering these
whalebones with a federal agency called
Noah I'm waiting to hear back from them
to find out what species of whale these
might belong to and whether or not I get
to keep the bones unfortunately I don't
know how long the process is going to
take so I'm going to go ahead and end
the video now and once I hear back from
them I'll post the results on The
Outdoor Boys Facebook page but hopefully
you guys enjoyed this video and you want
to see more if you do make sure to click
subscribe to the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and I'll see you guys next video
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for
watching